like you I am trying to adapt trying to
figure out how to exist in quarantine I
have to tell you honestly that for many
many years my children didn't quite know
what I did for a living
I I didn't want them to know that I was
in show business I wanted to keep them
distant from all that I thought that
would be healthier so for most of their
childhood up until two weeks ago my kids
thought that was a long-haul trucker
yeah true story I would come home every
night and just before I walked into the
house I'd put on a trucker's cap and I
walk in and go well that was a long haul
for this here trucker and then I'd spit
out what I thought was tobacco juice hmm
someone's playing the piano downstairs I
had a whole opening here that I've never
been thought a parent would get annoyed
by their child practicing the piano too
much but every time I start to try and
do something they play the piano okay
now it's a song and why can't you spend
time on tick-tock or something classical
music